[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
good morning guys so I am in Mexico in
Tulum to be specific and I just woke up
in our gorgeous hotel like a Gio
she looks so good with the whole light
in front of her and her whole reflection
this is our bed it's like this whole hat
canopy pet bed oh my goodness I cannot
speak right so the time difference here
is three hours ahead so we wanted to get
breakfast it's 7 a.m.
technically it's 4 a.m. for us Gio and I
didn't go to sleep until 3 a.m. here so
which was midnight back home because
we've just kept talking I'm laughing
because it's like all calculations in
time and some yeah I'm trying to wake up
so we can enjoy this place we're here
for only a few days but this hotel is
amazing it's right on the beach I got to
start getting ready
I could do this so this is our room
check that out that's so cool this room
is super super bohemian and that's the
balcony all right so we're all ready
dressed because we're about to do it
yoga class but first we're in Africa
look how beautiful this is
this is gorgeous so I decided not to
wear makeup today because for what nice
and warm and we're at the beach and I'm
just hoping that we get enough Sun so I
could get a nice little tan gonna be a
[Applause]
[Music]
while we Wow this is beautiful I wish
you were here this place is so romantic
[Applause]
[Music]
and this place is so cool I just love
this old hotel and these ladies morning
now on this channel geo Walmart take it
away
I mean well my my my my-y walmart
partnership has ended but because geo
each other boots too much that's what I
know now we gotta blame too you know but
yeah so we got here really late last
night it was already night time so I was
like yeah why even show you guys
anything it was like really dark I
couldn't see anything myself because
this whole hotel like the lighting is
really good it's really plenty too
because there's seven girls on this trip
we'll six so far because Gina's not here
yet but every single girl on this trip
is gonna be blogging so make sure to
check out all the girls channels put in
the description that's why instead it's
so funny
I did are you making fun of me because I
say that's so funny all the time please
it it's so funny because there's six
girls here we're all vlogging it is
funny that's so funny
Thank You Nikki alright so after we
finished eating we decided before you're
our yoga class man that was a tongue
twister we are going to go swim because
there's a 40% chance that it's gonna be
raining while we're here and it's not
raining right now so we're like let's
take advantage and make the most out of
the beach
[Music]
like what's the point of wearing this
dress it just opens wide open it's
pointless your channel does you can't
show it this much no that's nice okay
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
the beach is amazing the water is
amazing and these girls are amazing
please your channel
cover it up cover it up man after
sitting in the water though it's like
super salty my nostrils in my eyes are
like burning but other than that it was
amazing it was amazing
I love the views here take it over well
- the tractor but I changed it over
these views
just so amazing they're like a little
paradise can enjoy nature without
technology and I'm using the camera and
filming to just finish our yoga class it
was relaxing actually fell asleep it was
like in yoga it's like a different type
of yoga where it's like really elongated
poses and you're just really meditating
and like I fell asleep but I'm it is so
relaxing yeah this place is so cool
doughnut hole set up here it's just so
bohemian I love it so I found out
jeana's not gonna make it she wasn't
able to come after all so it's just us
the six of us oh my gosh I'm slurring my
words it sound like I'm drunk with it
I'm just we'd be drunk we're gonna see
what else we get ourselves into today I
miss Casey I miss Isaac they would have
loved it here I feel like we have to
come back because this place is so nice
boom make it go I don't know worried
about that once
are the only ones that drink things yeah
we are happy yeah they were that way the
boat oh I need a girl like my thoughts
cuz I am a little bit buzzed I had one
nickel on already hit me I didn't really
eat a lot this morning but Nikki and I
are the kind of drunks that were like
[Applause]
and I was just telling her I'm like oh
my gosh it's about to come out I'm about
to start telling you guys how much I
love you which reminded me I brought
their Christmas presents you're getting
it now
get drunk love it you're gonna love this
because I love it so much
[Laughter]
Hey so we each get a slice of us to keep
that so than you oh yeah there's seven
slices look Gina's not knows that but
anyway I got her a slice too so yeah he
called Gina oh here's one for everyone
pass it around I knew small little
miniature things for your prism I have
anywhere I'm not good at finding things
oh you're so sweet yeah Gina gave me for
Christmas like Hester
yes iron skillet oh my gosh those are
gay yeah but it's the mini one oh this
is adorable but I don't cook like how am
I gonna feel right now we put mine on
I know Nikki has been on this thing the
whole time saying this is the shadow
week after my retrograde which is like
like mercury goes like in the difference
I don't know what the hell it is but
pretty much she's saying that yeah bad
luck during Mercury retrograde in a last
three week but then last week is the
shadow week which is this week the
planets you all control your actions
make sure to be safe I don't be part of
it is those okay Casey you requested
that I drink a pina colada
this is my second one now I forgot to
record the first one there you go guess
what IG today I do the shot see it looks
good now baby and I are hanging out in
this hammock we want to see the ocean
but also we don't want to get up
campaign oh this having it's so comfy
bill if I'm cute and the castles and
stuff and then finally the Sun came out
we're like yeah we should go and enjoy
the beach yeah here's holy I'm Christina
geo went to go get our bathing suits
from our room we're gonna change again
oh my god third time getting into
bathing suit but it's just the weather
keeps playing tricks on our emotions
we're like man it's like pouring rain
where there is a woman for sure we're
out of it now but it's the shadowy
that's true told us about you been
learning yeah hopefully the Sun is being
nice and cool nightly Alan is Bill Nighy
is so nice right now is 3 p.m. so have a
good amount of daylight that Jeana can't
be here I know Jeana you suck you should
[ __ ] Tina but I love you but you saw
badass badass
oh man yeah we're the only two that have
been drinking if you have it
the water actually looks blue in person
so much today I took like three showers
too because after every time we swam in
the ocean I just immediately with go
shower that everyone's like no let's go
back in the water so I'm like okay so
yeah I was like you know I learned my
lesson for tomorrow I'm not gonna shower
immediately after going in the beach
because most likely we're gonna get it
again and again then again but it was
really fun I was just so tired right now
I was like in and out of a nap and like
trying to be part of the conversation in
the girls conversation but anyway right
now we're about to have lunch or no
dinner we're about to have dinner
the seafood spot it's like supposed to
be really delicioso
wine menu I can get a menu menu anyway
we're gonna eat no menus who showered
ladies sorry I'm actually I'm dirty
sorry you're gonna shower to leave oh
man you don't get a menu
[Music]
good morning day two I guess if you
don't count the first day when we got
here you woke up this morning and look
how beautiful it's so sunny it's like
super super sunny to bed there's all
these palm trees in front of us we can't
see the ocean but I could hear it anyway
we're about to go have breakfast
Leo and I the girls are doing the yoga
class the do and I wanted to sleep in
we're just like oh man we're just too
tired yeah so we slept in last night it
was so funny so we were playing all
these games and we ended up playing
never have I ever like a million times
so I ended up discovering a lot about
each other it was really fun we had a
lot of bonding time with the girls so
it's been really great this trip has
been really relaxing honestly because
this place doesn't have the best Wi-Fi
at least not from my phone because
everyone else can connect but my phone
is being really trippy and I can't
really connect which is fine in the
moment I'm like bothered by that cuz I'm
like I need to check my emails I gotta
do this I gotta do that but then in the
grand scheme of things I'm like no it's
actually a good thing that I can't
connect so I could be disconnected it's
just
spend time with my friends and enjoy the
nature here we're gonna go eat breakfast
was delicious look at the beach so
you've been having lunch and I ordered
the octopus and it's seasoned so yummy
it's like really limey and it's really
tender and came with these potatoes no
but I'm like in the middle of eating it
and I was like look I made a heart
they're like you should put this in your
videos like oh yeah you're right so I
put up camera and there you go there's
my octopus port and this is a view while
we're eating lunch
the girls ordered a bunch of food how
have you been enjoying this trip so far
it's good it's been relaxing and I feel
like today's the best day because the
weather is so good
yeah now we get to be in the water most
of the day and I'm pretty sure we would
be going in in LA ten times a day today
I just miss my boys I miss my girls I
know I bet we're in this gratitude tent
it looks so cool and we're about to do a
sound bet with all the girls
this whole place is gonna be packed with
people and pretty much with the sound
what a sound Beth is is they play like
these sounds and then they bathe you in
it you just lay down here you kind of
meditating and soak it all in this tent
is so nice this
the last day we're leaving today we just
have a couple more hours this paradise
it's been awesome and no makeup all
weekend
no shoes all weekend cuz everywhere here
it's like all sandy like not
I just haven't need to worry about
anything it's just been getting in to
the water and then out relaxing and
lounging and it's just been awesome so
I'm really gonna miss this place and I
really hope KC is convinced through this
video that he wants to come here too and
then we can come back because I know KC
doesn't like this type of vacation where
you just lounge around and do nothing
and just enjoy nature he's more of a
city person and like a culture person so
I don't think he's gonna like this but
hopefully he does cuz I really want to
come back alright they've just took our
luggage we are officially checking out
of this room but I realized that I don't
think I gave you guys a room tour really
so now that it's daytime and now that
we're leaving you can see the room Gio
and I stayed in balcony I showed you
guys that
and then here's the bathroom area
toilets behind that door shower and
that's it we're out our room was on the
second floor we have to go up these
stairs and then they have this little
Bowl here for you to rinse off your feet
every time you want to go to your room
which I thought was really cool and then
there's all these planets that light up
at night time look it just looks like a
jungle paradise look at the wind time we
were here the first night we got here
and so we got to see all this in the
dark like what this is so cool there was
a lot of lights illuminating the time so
many don't like little art installations
and incorporating nature went down and
beautifully this place is a really like
yogi kind of place they have yoga every
morning - I like it maybe more when you
was a little younger is you know like
really little kids they can have fun and
like the most random places now is it's
too old too
to be stimulated a lot more we're out of
here I'm the only one that's was trying
to give us up yeah everyone I'm blogging
ran out okay ready and action
Hey
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
no semen was good I was impeccable
it smelled very nice yeah you're
thoughtful and considerate of each other
you're the best roommate aware the best
roommate ever next time we have a
complication the guys are down right all
right we're bringing her into it
I'll give us one bench
[Music]